so the other day you know I said that we
could uh start by talking about this
audio leak of Donald Trump that CNN put
out but I said you know the rule is you
gotta wait a couple days before you do
because the context will always change
the narrative was that Donald Trump was
caught on tape saying he had these
documents and they were classified
then the league comes out everybody
hears it the view and many others say
this is damning evidence Trump's going
to go to jail this is proof positive now
we're learning that the whole story was
a hoax sure the audio exists Donald
Trump was talking about declassifying
certain stories but it appears now that
Donald Trump wasn't actually holding
classified documents in the audio he was
talking about a news report that had
come out a few days earlier
and uh Trump is not being charged in
relation to anything having to do with
the Iran memo